Wow.
Well go to your mom's house,
Christina.
And now time to get into this.
We have a fits dogs on the way and um,
you ready gene? Woo. Ready to have
some fun. Ready? Okay, here we go.
Here we go. Pay Attention. I'm paying
attention to turn that ringer off.
I can't because I'm waiting for a very
important phone call. Okay, here we go.
All right, let's, she's been
carded. She's your daughter.
She's retarded.
Told you tango started
bringing in one loving coded.
Well,
I like
Christina pushes.
It's interesting.
Yeah.
Ooh,
she's retarded.
Is that how you feel when we're out in
public you and I'm embarrassing you and
you want to tell people that
this is a like a boards.
This is say a button on a bus.
Retarded.
I think it's the boyfriend of a lady
who's acting out and the bus driver asked
him to get off the bus and they refuse.
The cops are right there.
She spits on one of them. Oh dear.
So then they kind of like, you know,
push her back onto the bus to arrest her.
And that's when the guy's like, don't,
she's retired. She doesn't know
what she's doing. And then somebody,
some PC or on the, on the bus
goes, it's mentally. Yeah,
I think it might even be one.
So here she is and they're
like, let's go. Go. Oh,
okay.
There you go.
There's Christina just
leaving during our show. Oh,
okay.
That's a fun new way to do this program.
Who cares about the cohost?
I'll just, and then I can,
I can hear her through there.
That's awesome. You good?
Oh Great. Great. If you want to join
the show, that was, that would help.
Well, you know what
column? I think for me,
I don't know what call you're
waiting for. Oh really? No.
I remember when I went to the appointment
I went to right before this. Yeah.
Oh yeah, but you didn't tell me that's
the call you're waiting for. Oh yeah,
that's a long way. Right? Okay. Yeah.
All right, here we go. So here's the
ladies round to
just spit towards the cop.
She said,
oh no, no, you're not.
I think he's retarded return.
That is a good way to get out of behavior.
That's not acceptable. You
know, like started. Yeah.
Yeah. He say, I am retarded.
That's another one. You should
try it. Well, that's about it.
If you ever do anything for
sure from now on in public,
that's not socially acceptable. I'm going
to go. She's retarded. She's retarded.
Yeah.
The PC here has to tango started.
Word is developmentally disabled.
The PC police has to fucking all
the leases on the bus. Yeah. Okay.
I don't think they did that.
They rode the bus and the guy who's
saying she's retarded is her boyfriend,
caregiver, whoever. It was close to her.
Yeah. He's not troubled by the word.
She's certainly not disputing it.
She's like,
I'm not retarded.
I'm mentally disabled.
She sounds retarded.
Bula Schumer
mentally to say somebody's a really
gets upset about it. There is that.
The cop is that one of the other
cops, listen, he gets really upset.
Jeff through this develop.
Don't say the word retarded and then
he's like, no, no, she's retarded.
He's retarded. If you knew her, you know
how I'm with her all the time. She's 24,
seven retarded.
I told you you were going
to lay a, that made my day.
That really made my guys guys, guys,
I'm with her all the time. Trust me.
She's retarded.
Yes.
Yes
guys, it's table, um, cash.
Check it out but just did hot yoga number
12. It's been ruining our home
life. Too many messages. Too many.
You're gone for hours every day cause
we're doing 90 minute fucking classes.
Well I don't get it cause your,
let's say your class is like one,
everyone's sick of it by the way. I'm sure
it was Joe's idea. She was sick of it.
I'm so fucking sick of yoga.
No one wants to do 15 classes in a month
about anything. It's a lot. No, no.
Have you achieved enlightenment of some
sort? I do feel like at the end of,
of all the classes you do have a
definite sense of clarity. It's a good,
it's a good place to go if you have
a decision weighing on your mind.
I think like whether or not to call
somebody retarded or developmentally
challenged, I don't know yet. And
then at the end of class I'd be like,
she's retarded.
So you really do.
What happens is hot yoga,
Bikram Yoga class. Um,
a good portion of it is
basically meditation. If
you're in a meditative state,
which I think Burt could really benefit
from. Oh, Berta specialty. Yeah.
Has he been able to sign everyone does
silenced his monkey mind? I don't know.
I think so. I think he
isn't in a different place.
It would be. We should do,
we should see him again soon. We should
bring him back and get an update.
Good enough. Did you leave for hot?
You're like, oh class is that one.
I'll be home at seven.
You're hilarious.
It's so funny how we
breakdown for this audience,
what it's like to be with you in this.
So classes are 90 minutes long.
90 okay.
It's hot yoga in on the class schedule.
If you'll go online,
it tells you to arrive.
Please arrive 15 minutes before class.
So your 90 minutes is now 105 minutes.
Class doesn't start exactly on time.
Mostly the class would start, you know,
five to 10 minutes after
the scheduled time,
which means it ends five to 10
minutes after the scheduled time.
So if you're talking about driving to
this thing, arriving a little bit early,
doing the full class when you're done,
it's 104 degrees in the room.
It's like you jumped into a pool and
then you got to let all those parts out
that you've been holding the farts
out. You've got to take a shower. Um,
there's a single shower, wait
a minute, what you're like no,
cause you were like you came home in her
day and you're like, I'm like, cause I,
I showered there and I go, all of you
shower there. I mean what, what Yoga,
I've never heard of a yoga,
Yoga, yoga studio, honestly,
where you could shower after. I
have, I have never heard of it.
But you haven't been to a Bikram yoga
class. But that's what I'm in. So
understanding, but I'm saying
that you're like me and the guys,
we shower together after and I was
like a group shower and you're like,
yes, a group shower. And I thought that
was a little fishy. The ladies shower too.
So everybody showers. Showers. Yeah.
I think the only person that I've seen
not shower there as Bert because he just
gets in his car. Oh wait a minute. Soaking
wet, but it's not really a group shower.
She fits. This is weird. Yeah.
We just hit pause. We're back. Uh,
Fitz Simmons just came in fits dog the
Great Greg and we were talking off mic.
Uh,
he's actually a hot Yoga Bikram Yoga
practitioner as well. He loves it, right?
Isn't it pronounced beek rum? Yeah. Okay.
All right. Should I open your mic
or no? Yeah, that would be good. Oh,
there you are noticing.
I can,
I can't hear anything because you
didn't turn his headphones up,
which you return those
probably number two. There
we go. Yeah. That's good.
That's good. Yeah. Yeah. I haven't done
it a ton, but I used to do it every year.
I went to San Francisco because that's
where it kinda started, I think. Yeah.
And I would go up and I would do the
punch line and I would always go in on
Saturday. And do a hot yoga
class and uh, you know,
so it was once a year, but then I
started doing it with a buddy in Venice.
They got one in Venice.
That's really good. Yeah.
I mean, so I've gone to, I went
to my 12th one of the month today.
Supposed to 15 right.
So I have to go tomorrow's number
13 and then just two more. Okay.
Thanks for adding that up.
I wasn't sure if team work
cause 13 concept and then
it goes 1415 that's if you
know like all, all right. And you
do that off the top of your head.
I can just throw another number at me.
I'll just say,
so you go one and then
you get good. Two, three,
408 you started seven Oh yeah,
that'll take it out. Right.
But Christine's favorite kids
joke of all time. That was why.
Why is five afraid of six to seven eight,
nine,
six three to seven because
seven ate nine is that it? Yeah.
He never red bubble gum wrappers? No. No.
And then you can see more of these if
you watch was new, special, inferior.
It's on Netflix right now.
Love dead.
Lot of dad jokes
to Mary for there to be a group shower
after she thinks it's crazy that I shower.
I'm like I'm a group shower
pool after this now that's what happens.
It's a matter of fact,
I'd never seen my friend Matt,
Matt Molloy.
I'd never seen him naked before and I was
okay with it because it wasn't like we
had just jumped into a cold
lake and then we're doing it.
This was like I had some nice hang.
Sure.
I had some Nice puffy flesh Gordon Brown
sweating for awhile in there. Yeah I
know it's weird cause like we have a,
it's a very small locker room and it's
a single shower so people have to wait
and like some of the guys walk into the
shower stall with their shorts on and
I'm a dick out guy. Like I, I take it off,
I sure I stand naked in the locker room.
It's kind of really a separation of like
who's have grown up in here, you know,
cause like I feel like the, no,
I'm serious. It an immigrant.
It's the real Russian
immigrant style. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. Give a shit. Well it's um,
I was a very skinny kid and I had,
I hit,
I hit puberty at like I was close
to 15, I think when I hit. Yeah.
So I remember freshman hockey,
I used to go,
I used to go to practice
not making this up.
I was so embarrassed to
even take my pants off.
Did I used to strap my shin
guards and put my pants,
my hip pants on over my jeans
and I would play hockey with my jeans
on underneath. That's crazy. Excellent.
Cause I was so embarrassed
by my twiggy little legs.
I hairless twiggy little lag.
Really. You thought you're going to be
mocked by others like the other kids?
I was horrified about my body.
And so,
and then I would hitch hike home because
the rank was like 20 minutes away and
it was,
this is New York in the wheelchair.
I would stand on the side of the
highway in January. Drenched wet. Yeah,
the we raised. Where
were your parents? Had?
One of my teachers picked me up on the
side of two 87 and they drove me home.
It was,
it was way out of her way to take me all
the way home and then they call my mom
the next day and they were like,
do you know that I picked your son up
hitchhiking last night at nine o'clock
until 87 and my mom went like, well, how
else was he going to get home? It's like,
oh. I picked him up and
driven up not only that,
never bought me any hockey equipment.
I used to bum like old skates off
friends and I remember going through the
garbage and the locker room and finding
broken shin pads and then taping them on
with tape.
I'd find tape rolls that were thrown
out that weren't completely gone and I
would use those because they never bought
me a piece of sporting equipment and
my life and I played sports.
How do they not buy you?
I meanwhile we had money.
That's even worse.
That's even worse because my mom grew up,
both my parents grew up in the Bronx and
they didn't have any money and my mom,
especially like my
grandparents were from Ireland,
they came over here like
literally off the boat, nothing.
And so my mom grew up with seven
brothers and sisters and just like penny
pinched and she couldn't,
even though my father was in
radio and he made good money,
she couldn't spend the money. I feel the
same way. I know how many, how many kids,
how many siblings did you have?
A brother and a sister?
They're brothers, sisters. Everybody had
this experience then that your siblings.
Yeah, that's, that's wild. Yeah.
Is this something you guys talk about a
lot or no to so many other things to get
to? You know, that doesn't, that's
at the bottom of the list now.
It wasn't that bad. It's
a matter of fact, my,
my sister has said to my wife,
she doesn't get what me and my brother
are complaining about so much because she
thinks that everything was good and
bad, but fine. But isn't that funny?
She's the baby.
That's why
blings though when you talk
about the shared experience,
I always find that like I have two
sisters and I've heard in different,
in different scenarios,
uh,
either one of us having the, you
know, the totally different version
for you, younger or older. I'm a middle,
I'm the middle of the year, the metal.
But like I,
I think I'm, I'm, I mean I'm the most
even tempered of the three to begin with.
And then like my version of something
we'll always be usually more like a
recollection will be like, that
was pretty normal. And there's,
we're always be like more heightened,
more emotional exaggeration of something
I'll be like, no, that wasn't it.
I think,
I think you guys know this as parents,
you guys have gone through some pretty
major life in the last couple of years
and uh, I think you deal with a different
set of parents at any given time.
And birth order they say has a huge
effect on how you're treated. You know,
the first one there, they're nervous,
they're scared. That kid can be neurotic.
They could end up being hyper achieving
because there's so much pressure on them
and in the middle kid can get lost a
little bit because then the younger one
gets the,
it's the baby we gotta you know,
and then the younger one
generally gets treated the best,
but they also feel the most pressure
to not cause any issues there.
They tend to be super likable,
not have needs.
Boy, I think that was me in our family,
the middle, cause they were like,
the older kid had more like,
you know, shit going on and,
and acting out and then the baby
was the baby and they're like,
is the good thing about you is that
you're, you're not demanding. Like to me,
you know,
they were like,
that's the great thing about
you is that you're a nice kid.
Easy to deal with you.
You're not causing us anyway.
Yeah. And I was like, look,
you right in the eye when they
say it. Yeah, you're nice.
Everybody likes you stay without causing
any problems, which keep grades. Okay.
You don't get drunk and you're
just taking it all in. Good.
Those are my marching
orders. Of course. Yes.
And I don't think they consciously realize
that they're telling you to do that.
You know,
I think they think part of them thinks
like they're just like telling you how it
is that they're actually
telling you what to do.
Yeah. You know, I don't know if
they processed that at the time. Um,
I think subconsciously you tell your kids
a lot and I'm starting to become more
aware of that because my
kids are so different.
My son is like boom,
straight A's,
captain of the soccer team, captain
of the club, soccer team, girlfriend,
steady friends. I'm the
nicest, most even keeled.
Like I literally couldn't tell you
what I would change about this kid.
And then sometimes I wonder,
am I, is he being that way?
Because we're subtly demanding
that of him. Right. Oh, right.
Because he's almost too good, right? Yeah.
And you're not aware of it. Obviously.
You know,
you don't know until later when your
kids tell you that you were a bad parent.
God, there's no way you were bad.
You weren't bad. I go, I travel.
I feel like maybe that
has an effect on them.
You may have gone every other weekend,
but your wife is there. Right.
So somebody's got a full time mom for
17 years, so somebody is always there.
Same with Tom and I, we take
turns traveling, but one of
us is always there. Yeah,
I think that's the key,
right? No, we don't both.
And don't let your kids hitchhiked.
Don't you love how that, that's this,
that's that far gender people hitchhiked.
I grew up here in the San Fernando
Valley. I just saw some, uh,
like a grown man who's doing that?
Who's doing that? Fuck. Are you doing?
I hitchhiked.
I used to,
I used to work as a caddy at a golf
course that was like 15 minutes away.
And I used to get up at like six o'clock
in the morning and I would get on the
road and I would hitchhike to work.
And then I would caddy like two loops.
I was like 14 years old and I would
carry two loops. Two giant. I told you I
was skinny. I was, yeah. And
then I would, uh, hitchhike home.
Who would pick up cause you got,
you got a bunch of rides.
So sometimes it took a long time.
Yeah.
Was it, um, questionable people
picking you up usually or,
I never had a bad experience.
Not once. Nope. My friend Pete,
who is my best friend, we
hitchhiked together a lot.
Yeah. And uh, he had a guy,
he went, he went to school in the
Bronx and so he had a guy pick them up,
two different guys twice picked him
up that were jerking off. Wow. Yeah.
I could see that happening
a lot. But yeah. For guys,
here's the crazy thing
about this whole, um, uh,
what's his name? Harvey
Weinstein thing. Yeah.
Okay.
And not to, you know, and you had some
very interesting opinions on it when Ya,
thank Christina did my podcast the other
day and I thought you had some very
brave takes on it. Me
Meetings. She would blow up
hi. PHRYGIA and her husband
would encourage her. Yeah.
That's a story. Not even scarring. I mean,
if it's a big enough fell,
that's what I'm saying. Yeah.
Like a big Hollywood movie to show me the
deck film for some film. Kidding. Yeah.
Guy. If a guy your deal,
that's not a big one.
I needed a ride and he
gave you that ride still.
I wouldn't mind if that's what I'm
saying. Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
And so I know a comedian who was kind
of mentored by another comedian. Huh.
And uh,
the older comedian brought him over his
apartment one night and he jr he just
started jerking off
the front of them and the guy just left
and he fucking still considers him like
a mentor still. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's just like, all right, so the,
the Guy Jerks. It's, it's almost
like, you know, I believe me,
I'm not belittling the Harvey Weinstein
thing or anybody need to even say what
I'm in the middle of saying no.
But I think
is funny thing about guys is like guys
forgiving guys doing like guys can also
feel like somebody could act
violently, right? Yeah. Uh,
a man and a woman be like,
I'm gonna stay away from that
guy for the rest of my life.
And a guy can act violently
and in front of another guy,
like a friend I was saying,
and he'll still like, he'll
get over, he'll be like, oh,
I have fist fights with like a,
you know,
you guys externalize
your anger. He, you know,
he punched a hole in that wall and
broke that guy's job. But like, yeah,
he's a good guy. No, we don't do,
I used to fist fights with my close
friends and we would get over it. I mean,
it would take a week. Yeah. And
then we'd be over it. Yeah. Yeah.
But I hear stories about guys jerking
off in front of each other too,
like sleepover parties. When you're
a, you've heard those stories, like,
I never heard those stories.
My guy friends were like, yeah,
we used to have sleeping bags and we'd
sleep on either side of the bed and we'd
watch some movie. And then
we both jerkbait that's me.
Sarah, you did that? Yeah.
No, I used to go over, across the street.
Uh, my friend's house, I won't say his
name but, but we would, uh, he would have,
you know,
everyone be sleeping bags and then
we would put it on the spice channel.
But spice didn't come in. You would,
it would snow. You're right. And
then you'd get like some,
some get a random,
I'll get a random shot and then everyone,
no one would be like, hey check me out.
But everyone will be like humping the
floor or like you could, you could feel,
you know, all the wrestling
and the sleeping bags and
then people would be like,
and then we're like 10, 11,
and then everyone pass out.
And that was like a
sleepover on like a Friday,
Saturday night for a year or two
that was happening all the time.
Never talked about when talked about it
was, yeah. It wasn't like people have,
cause it was at the age of like
starting to do that. In other words,
it's not like you're 15, 16, you've been
doing it for awhile. It was like 10,
11 years old. So it, you
wouldn't even know earlier
here hit puberty. Like I said,
I guess that was 21.
I was pouring Greg,
I mean 15 years old.
And that kicks in like did you have
some kind of pituitary thing or why?
I don't know. I don't know.
I'm just like, I'm not even,
I didn't have hair for a long time and
uh, you know, I've kind of a high voice.
I'm a, I'm a feminine man and what
I've always tried to overcompensate,
you're really not.
But I've always tried to overcompensate
by being tough and being aggressive,
like a little cocky, sharp tongue,
still sharp tongue. But you know,
that's all hiding. Uh, you
know, your early years of
having a shame with my body.
Um,
and our high school,
so I switched high schools and
when I arrive at high school,
I'm a freshman so I switched her my
freshman year and after the first football
practice, I'm a, I'm a freshman
but I'm playing with, you know,
I'm on the Varsity team cause we're,
we're doing a spring ball,
so I'm playing for the first time in
spring football on the varsity team.
So people are getting after practice,
taking their pads and their stuff off.
And I noticed all the guys going into
the shower with their boxers on and like,
it's so weird. So what happens is
nobody wanted to shower naked, but why?
Just they were just, it was, I dunno, but
here's the thing, like I'm a freshman,
so I came from,
I switched from a school where everybody
was showering naked because it's a
shower.
But since I,
I switched and there's upperclassmen
wearing boxers in the shower.
I just kept my boxers on too.
Because you didn't want to be the person
who's insisting on being naked. Yeah.
So people showered with their boxers on
and then took their boxers off once they
had a towel around them.
And this is, this is like,
I'm 14 and these are like
1718 year old guys shower,
showering in their boxers.
You think
actually the shower that the most integral
part of the shower is the asshole on
the ball said, right? Yeah. And
those boxes are so football boxers,
like you just ran around and just, you
know, it's just gnarly, man. Yeah. Yeah.
Wow.
Nobody except for like,
by the time I was a senior,
the one kid who we suspected was gay
and definitely turned out to be gay,
was walking around without that was it?
That was the only kid.
It's like you're black.
And he had a big fucking Dick on him
too, so he was like, Hey, what's up?
It's out here.
I've spent so little time around
naked guys at the Friar's club.
I used to belong to the
Friar's Club in New York. Yeah.
And they have the best
steam room in New York City.
It's like this old marble and a, this is
going to sound crazy, but I swear to God,
this is true. You go in and it's so old
school Jewish that when you walk in,
you put on a towel and you sit down and
then this, this Yugoslavian guy comes in,
this old Yugoslavian guy and he brings
you ice water and a towel that's been
dunked in ice.
And he hands it to you.
And so you sit there and it's
completely balls. Once you get in there,
it's balls out. Yeah. Yeah. And
so it's all these old dudes.
And their sacs are like hanging over the
bench and down towards the floor. Yeah.
There, you know, the PDC can't tell if
they have a big penis or it just melted.
His skin is flopping over Fishkin and
gravity and life has just written on these
bodies and these splotches of hairs,
sometimes you don't even have they shaved
or did the hair just fall out? Yeah.
And so,
and so you finished with the shower
and then you walk to the Shah,
you finished with the steam and you walk
to the shower and they have these giant
fucking marble sided showers with,
um,
with a man hole covers size,
shower head on it.
And it blasts like a thousand gallons
a second. You feel, it's like,
it's like being in a civil rights riot.
This German shepherds barking underneath
the seat and then you shout and then
you, uh, and then I would jerk off a lot,
not because I just saw this
Dick's just because I was I 22,
and I was just jerking off all the time.
Sure.
And so I would jerk off and then uh,
I would come out and the Yugoslavian guy
would wait for you and you have a dry
towel and he would put it around your
shoulders and then he would pat you dry
your neck and your arms and your back
then your butt and your legs and your
feet. He would pat. Is that, is that yes.
And your peer that yes, it is.
So in Hungary, that guy, oh,
a tip every day when you leave.
Yeah, it's normal. And Hungary,
there's the thermal baths.
It because the Turks were in Hungary
at some point and so they have a, the,
you know, famous Miguel air and hotel and
you, you get buck naked and, and yeah,
someone pats you down, they're very
hands on. They can be very hands on,
don't you dare get a massage at the
Gellert cause that's like, you know, your,
your buck naked.
And then like the Big Lady,
we'll open the curtain and like people
will be walking by and you're just
getting slapped and slathered
with that soap. It's, it's,
they're not as squeamish as Americans
are about the body. Definitely.
Yeah.
I think the Irish are very squeamish.
I think it's probably a Catholic thing.
Yes. Yeah. Yeah. I've, I've always, yeah,
it took me a long time. I'm not, I'm
still not comfortable with my body,
but should we get naked? You want to look
good naked? I'll do hot yoga with you.
I'm at right now. That's what I'm
saying. Yeah. And then we'll do hot yoga
because it's going to get hot.
I'll tell you after having
a kid, I don't give a shit.
And I think it's because you,
when you give birth you're wide open.
And like I was pushing
Ellis out as I was pushing,
the nurses had a shift change,
so it was like five new people
got to see my coach. No, but yeah,
like I don't care. I'm done. My
body is a functional thing. Yeah.
Like I don't feel weird about it.
Yeah. I think I feel less weird than
I used to. You know, like I, uh,
I used to bench press a lot because
that was how I overcame being skinny.
He's like in college I actually got
kind of, not big, but you know bigger.
And the worst thing about that
is then you get older and you,
your tits ball might have yeah.
And, and the, and you know,
and it's just so fucking embarrassing to
the point where you get so embarrassed
that you stopped being embarrassed. Right?
Yeah. You just let go into it. Yeah,
that's right. Surrender. Surrender
to your ugly, Shitty Yadie
and that's what you end up. It's funny
cause you had your party admirers.
I do like the notably flawed
person who really doesn't care.
You know what I mean? And then
you're like, I want to be like that.
And then sometimes you become like that
and you're like, oh I'm back. You're like,
I just don't care anymore Bobby Lee.
Well and if you can notice if you,
if you go on vacation or to
any ocean or pool, most people
we'll have shitty bodies. That's
right. Yeah, that's right.
It's a small section that I'm good.
And when I do see them,
I think I'm glad I'm looking at
their body, but I think to myself,
how much time and work went into
their life this moment. Yeah. Yeah.
This, yeah. You know, how many moments
do people get to see their body?
Like when we saw a perfect
dad and that last vacation,
he's a perfect day saw perfect dad
fucking like Swedish Donnis for sculpted,
just everything. But the V
fucking the lower, you know,
the lower ab,
right.
Good feet holding one kid and
walk with the other world,
like beautiful motherfucker. Get the
time to do it, to work out with him.
And his wife was like, okay, it like
an okay shape, but this dude was just,
I mean he looked, I was like, I
bet this guy's an Olympian. Yeah.
That's the type of build he had.
Yeah.
But like he stood out amongst hundreds,
like everybody else was dog shit.
Yeah. Well, how do you feel with the body
change that you've just gone through?
I mean,
do you feel like you want to go out on
the beach and show people your body now?
No,
I think it's, you know, it's different.
I was actually telling someone about it.
It's like you change happens with,
with like with your weight
and everything slowly. Yeah.
And I think it just, you kind of
get, it reinforces to you like,
oh, like this still sucks pretty
badly. Like my body, I'll be like, oh,
like you're still,
you're still pretty fat and it's been,
a lot of weight is gone.
But then I always try to remind myself
of like how getting out of shape actually
took a long time because what happens
is like when you're, when you're in it,
when you really are like really
eating well and working out,
it can be frustrating when you just,
some random day you're like,
I eaten poorly in a month and I've
done nothing but work out. And um,
and you just see like you're fat shitty
flaws and you're like, that sucks.
But then you go like, yeah,
but to get out of shape,
it wasn't like I ate three bad meals,
you know what I mean?
It was neglect and sitting and
eating shitty food for years to,
to put on that weight.
So yeah,
a month or two months or six months
is not going to be like all that,
all that bad shit is gone. It takes a
long, long time. Yeah. Yeah. But I think,
I mean with me like I definitely
don't feel like, Oh wow, this is like,
I joke around, you know, like I
know t's Bert and uh, you know,
but like I know I feel like I'm in
terrible. You Look Great Tommy. I
compliment you. And every day you do,
you look great. Well thanks. So hands
on your face will be so different.
Your body looks fantastic, I think. I
mean, you look great heavy. Thankfully.
I like you both ways. I like skinny.
Yeah, you definitely tolerated that.
Tolerate it. Okay. How about
your body? You sucked off
the, the mom you weight fast.
Do you think? Yeah, you look good. I
dropped out. Yeah. I got real fat now.
You know, you just don't eat carbs or
sugar or have fun. No alcohol, suffering.
It's just you have to suffer. That's just
it. Yeah. There's no easy way. Right?
You just suffer. Well, I guess
it's a matter of like your palate.
I think for some people you get addicted
to carbs and so the withdraw from carbs
and sugars is very intense,
intense.
And I think for some people they
just were never that into carbs.
So it's not that big a deal. When
I think about, yeah, I've had,
I not even going to say out loud what
I want to say. Why? Well No, I should,
because I can tell you how horrifying it
was to be that skinny when I was little.
I literally eat anything that I want.
Yeah, no, I get it man up. But
everyone had like, I don't know man. I,
everyone has their own issue
with different things. Yeah.
So it's like I've never had the,
for me it's definitely food and
I definitely was eating a cray,
like I was thinking about once you make
a transition and for a while you're
conscious of your eating and you go,
how I used to eat was so insane. Yeah.
Well let me see his comedian.
Oh yeah.
And like what about like
eating with normal people and,
and like they would,
you know,
they would like a regular person would
see one of my meals as like an indoor,
like a vacation meal, I guess we'll
do this today. And I'd be like,
I do this every day.
Like I always do.
And like I would eat just like with,
I just no regard for her.
Give me like a regular
meal at a restaurant.
What you would order like an
appetizer and entree and a dessert.
Hundred percent. Yeah. And
like, and, and maybe like order,
another thing that like,
I just want to try that and,
and like another entree or aside maybe
both. No Shit. But I wouldn't even,
like I wouldn't fucking even process it.
And like I would have,
if I was on the road,
I would have breakfast,
I would have something like rich
and fatty, then I would be like,
I gotta have something sweet. So I
have like a waffle. And then like,
if they're like, have you seen this bakery
that has like, bib, amazing croissants,
I'd be like, let's go.
Let's go try it. Yeah.
I mean I think I'm going to throw ups
was wait like an hour and then when I'm
done, like once it digests, like I
just wouldn't, I wouldn't think that,
I wouldn't even think it was
that much of an indulgence.
I would think of normal Tommy.
We used to at our old house and a
bag in Redondo last time we saw you,
we used to make brownies. I would, I
would bake brownies like every night,
every night, and then we would eat
like half the tray nice and hot,
put some ice cream on that. And I'm
like, well no wonder, you know, we got,
and here's the other thing before I,
I always forget this,
before we invited the public
to shame us about being fat,
like Burt and I specifically, and we did
this weight loss challenge. Yeah, Dude.
When I would post things on social media,
maybe one out of 400 comments
would be about being fat.
Nobody would say anything to me. Nobody
was like, you're one person might,
you know, you're like,
oh, this guy's a dick.
Well because you're built to be fat
bill. I have a big fat. Yes, true.
What a great thing to say. You're
right. It's true. Are built to be. So
it would just be like, it's
fine. Yeah. Built to be fat.
That's a good name for a special
actually tee shirts shot.
I just shot it in this special
and I submitted the title,
but I think it might change.
It took the break
built to be fat. He's got the face
for it and you've got a big head.
Shoulders are broad. You had
a beard into that. Forget it.
You know what I might do?
Put on a hundred pounds and have another
special called built to be fun where
it's like I put it all back on,
right? Well, yeah. I mean, uh, um,
what's her name?
Got Pregnant again to do her next special
Allie. You know, people
are gonna say that too. Oh,
she did it again. Yeah,
but it's a ticking clock.
She's got to get the special
done, you know? I mean,
how old's the other baby
or babies like to, oh,
it's two already heard her
baby's going to be too, right,
right. Yeah. She's uh,
she's so fucking funny.
She's a great person. Good. Yeah,
she's really sweet. Um, so, okay,
so I have a gift for you
guys because you know, you,
um,
when you had the baby and uh,
Christina reminded me of this when I came
on, I got you guys a, uh, uh, a white, uh,
genie was a white or like a warm,
which by the way has become our
go to gift for. That's great.
When we think of it as like, oh, this
is what a comic should get. Yes. Yes.
And it's like,
you know,
when you think about a baby and you
think about how little control they have
about joy and all that stuff,
a hot on the asshole
is the best. It's just every single time
it would put the baby in a good mood.
Yeah. Yup. And by God, if you're about
to give me a notebook full of jokes,
I'm super appreciative because I have,
I need a new hour and I really,
well you remember that Greg, do you
remember that movie field of dreams?
If you build it they will come.
Yes. It's an empty notebook. Ah,
but here's what it is. Is this book
right here? Look in this. This is what I,
we kept since the start. Cause how
old is your kid now? Nine months.
No, he's almost two year olds to shut
the fuck up. Yeah, he's almost too
God
damn. All right. So I might be a
little late with this but not too late.
We started this,
somebody gave us this one when the,
when our first kid started talking
and it's, you write down every quote,
every cute thing that they
say are meaningful thing
and we've got it for years.
Oh and uh,
so I got you guys the same book.
Have you been keeping?
Yeah,
record of that.
I opened up an email account for Ellis
when he was born and we email him,
we sent him photos,
photos and stuff.
But this is direct quotes of
things. Then you know, we'll, we'll,
we'll say like today we did this. Yeah.
And like you said that. All right.
All right. This is fantastic. Thank you.
I brought mine so I could
read you a couple of good
ones that my kids, it's sad.
We'll start,
we've got to show that one. Yeah. Yeah.
This is special because it's handwritten
from Mommy and Daddy. That is very nice.
Very special.
You know how much like,
cause I was going to read this like
as we get and I'm 38 and like I have,
you know,
every year like your appreciation and
your relationship with your parents
changed. Yeah. Like if I was my eight,
like right now reading
this that my parents wrote,
yeah. I have such an impact.
Oh, already know this thing is
dogeared because my kids, uh, there,
there are 17 and 14, like to
sit around and read this. Oh,
there's nothing kids
when they're adolescents,
like more than to see pictures of
themselves and hear what they were like,
they love stories about themselves
because they don't know who they are yet.
Right, right, right. And they
think it's hysterical when,
when you show them that they
were cute. Um, all right.
Uh Oh. And what was
tired? And he said, um,
mommy more snores please. Do
you want to take a nap? Oh, I,
that's like so and uh, he said,
wait, let me find a good one.
Oh, this was the, the quote that
we still quote almost constantly.
We were in the airport and we're flying
from New York back to La and we had to
get up super early and Owen was three
ish and he was cranky and we've got some
breakfast, but we tried to give them
good food. So we tried to find oatmeal,
we couldn't find it. And so we ended
up having a buy him a chocolate muffin.
And so we give it to when he was
so excited, he was like shaking.
And then we said, but you can't eat the
whole thing. And I took the top off.
I said, you just eat the part that's
in the thing. And he goes, yeah,
you don't know all the rules about,
and to this day we constantly say,
you don't know all the rules about
whatever it is they were talking. Oh,
that's adorable. Tell me if this is too
corny. I just thought it would be, no,
we love it. I'm going to
do this for an email. Um,
because he just started talking.
He just started really
run your finger along the crack of your
ass. You don't need to figure your whole,
you don't want to come back
with shit on your finger.
And he was for, Jeez, this is Owen.
When he was, uh, six, uh,
I was carrying out a plate of fresh cut
pineapple and he said, come on Daddy,
let's go eat some heaven.
Oh, that's awesome. Yeah. Um,
I liked, I think my favorite thing
too is that he enjoys reading this,
but that's really good. Yeah. Um,
this is Jo Jo when she was about,
uh,
six violence. Mom, her
mom, her friend's black.
My father's mom has really
curly hair and wide fingernails,
but that's okay because she's
an extremely nice person.
Awesome.
Fantastic.
Am I qualifying it? You know, but
that's okay. Yeah. Yeah. You know,
he wasn't nothing. He not a race. She
was not a racist kid, but you know. Yeah.
Black and white is black
and white for sure.
And then this is another
black and white one. Um,
this is Owen before watching
a Michael Jackson video.
Is he going to be black or white in this
one? And then after watching the video,
he said I like his hair
better after the fire. Oh Man.
He was already slinging. Um, um, uh,
then this is Joe Joe, the first week
of school when she was in kindergarten.
Everyone at school is always
having fights to play with me.
I hate myself because it's
like I'm starting wars.
So when you want to hear these, you guys
would just run to the notebook. Oh yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. We should keep it
in like the kitchen or something. Yeah.
And then, um, she had like,
all of her friends were black
for some reason growing up.
Maybe it's because we live in a really
poor neighborhood now. We live in Venice,
so there's a lot of like
diversity. But she says, Mommy,
why do I like all the dark ones the best?
Okay.
Oh Man, that is so fun. And
this was a, here's a little one.
Act play after Jay. My kids make
fun of me going bald constantly.
It's their Goto. Thanks
Dale. Now. Oh yeah. Yeah,
but this is when they were really little.
Yeah.
A judge who was making fun of my
hair falling out and then Owen said,
don't listen to Joe, Joe Teasing you.
And I said, thanks Owen. And he went,
you're welcome baldy.
Right. I'm not going to keep
reading because I have no
idea if this is annoying.
It's really, really horrible. Yeah, we're
going to do it. Thank you for that. Yeah.
I remember that. Wanting to learn
who I was and what I was like.
The thing is that you feel like it's true.
It's like it gives you,
it gives you a sense of identity to
know what you were like, you know?
Because our memories are so selective.
I mean,
I read this thing about interviewing I
witnesses for jury pools and not your
pulls for eye witnesses for,
for trials.
And our ability to truly remember
what happened is like 0.1%.
It's like,
you know when and when you're talking
about your childhood with all the emotions
that go around it and you hear other
people telling the story about you.
So it's really their
version of who you were.
And so to have the actual quote from them
shows them as close to you as you can
get to who they really are.
And especially when my
daughter's racist story is,
is um, is something positive,
like a positive quality.
I think where if you're in that age where
maybe you're, you know, I don't know,
you're,
maybe you're a young teen and you're
shy and you're not sure of yourself and
they tell and you hear a story about
you being a little kid doing something
where you were assertive. You know,
it's like, it gives you confidence. Yes.
You go like, oh, like who I really am
is the story you're telling. You know,
it changes. It changes the way
you feel about yourself. Precise.
My parents saw me a story when I was a
kid because I grew up with a lot of black
kids too,
and there was a kid with the blacks.
There was a kid who invited me to his
birthday party and then I found out that
he didn't invite our friends. His name
is Yemi, a wallaby. He was from Africa,
didn't invite Yummy and so I said to
the kid who was like my best friend,
but his mother didn't want Yemi there.
I said I wouldn't go to the
party and I was only like seven.
He's not going on.
I'm like,
cause I figured then the
musical sock and nobody can dam.
I went to high school with a kid named
[inaudible] obituary who, damn. Yeah,
he was at for,
it's funny,
I was asking my dad to reminisce
when I give birth to Alice.
I was like, Dad, look what was I like?
How much did I weigh when I was born?
He goes, I don't know normal.
I'm his only child like you.
You do remember the one right?
Just normal car. Remember the time?
No, no, no, it was it where they did.
They have a lot of pictures of, you know,
Friday my mom put together an album.
Yeah, you must've been a cute little
kid. Was really attractive. Yeah.
God really? Qut. The pictures.
Oh I got real dark.
What was that like 1213 and the
darkness and the darkness came over.
Let me ask you this because
this is good to know.
My daughter now that she's 14 is going
into that place where she comes in the
front door and is in a room very quickly
and you don't see her except for dinner
and you know she's actually very sweet
but she can be pissy towards my wife.
When does that end and are you,
were you aware that you were doing that
and did you feel bad about it later? Oh,
I don't feel bad about it because
I was hiding from my family.
I didn't like being around them. Yeah. My,
my family is different than what you guys
had by far. Like what you have rather.
A lot of it is high school drama. Did
she just start high school? Yeah. Yeah.
So I think a lot of it is
like what happened at school
and she might be talking
to her girlfriends about it like, oh my
God, and then he did this or we did that.
Like you're analyzing a lot of what
happened to you if you're going to break
down the dad's. Cool. Yeah. So that
could be, I think that's really, it's,
it's like this girl world
that you inhabit at that age.
So it ends when you start to realize
you're not the center and like it doesn't
matter. Like by 16 I
think you're like, oh,
I'm not the only human around
and mom and dad are not that bad.
Quick to get out of it to page 17
my two sisters were really bad
my senior year. Really bad. Yeah.
I'm saying like with like kind of being
rude and Shitty to my parents and they
were over it before high school ended.
Yeah.
And they did feel bad and felt even worse
later once they had kids before even
having kids, like once you're
like in your 20s, they,
they would feel like really guilty about
how shitty their attitudes were. Yeah.
Yeah. Like they feel really bad
because like, they were like, you know,
like super embarrassed of them and
like just like era and they were just
oh yeah.
Snapping all the time. Yeah.
You're like, what the fuck man?
Like she's in ninth grade.
She's in ninth grade. Yeah.
That's a hard year. Ninth Grade,
the first year of high school.
So it's like this huge leap into becoming
a teenager. Like a legit teenagers.
Yeah. Well this device the
way make you feel bad. Let you
show me this. Uh, this, uh,
we, we were sent this
video, this lady, um, she,
she and her boyfriend were asked
to leave a bus and then, um,
she didn't want to leave the
bus,
so the police are outside the class.
Then she spit towards the cop. She said,
no, no, you're not
her boyfriend.
Well,
her boyfriend is trying to get this is
the boyfriend is trying to get her off,
like trying to get the policemen to not
arrest her just by repeating that she's
retarded.
So she's not accountable but
oh I didn't hear that.
Oh
she's retarded.
I told you tango started just retarded.
And did you see the PC police
step in and go mentally disabled?
Don't even pop was saying that. No, it's
another bus rider is like for seniors,
the word is developmentally
disabled and uh,
he continues like route as
they bring her off the bus.
Oh No,
she,
she's not developmentally,
he's correcting the guy that's trying to
help her. That's clearly her guardian.
Right? Yeah. Right. Speaking of which,
um, oh, we're doing a benefit, Christina,
and I think you're out of town.
I remember eighth at the comedy store
for the best buddies. That's cool.
Which is a group of developmentally
disabled people that thought the
developmentally disabled growing
this benefit for it. But it's cool,
but it's going to be Rogan.
Oh, Tony Hinchcliffe and uh, Pete Holmes.
Wow. Look at all star plus a
black act to be named later.
Cause you got to get one that
your daughter will say daughter.
Uh, I'll be in New York. I would love to
go. I'll be right. Yeah. It'll be fun.
It'll be fun to get your tickets to
the comedy store. Dot. November 8th,
November 8th. Definitely support that. Um,
so we will catch you up on something
that's been rolling into this week.
A few weeks ago somebody sent us this guy
who walking down the street decided he
was going to write a
song into camera and it,
there wasn't a lot going on in the song.
[inaudible] he
sing my song trying to sue my
song. Okay, here we go. Here we go.
I have another beat down for you. I
tried to practice talk, just my own song.
Just my introduction to my
song coming at Ya. Here we go.
She's retarded shoes with Dan machines
was then they got a gun I got again.
Yeah. It got a gun. Terminate
her gun. Yeah. Machines.
Then machines was thin. G 16. Geeze.
16 China wreck.
My Rep trying to make my RUC,
trying to talk to with flow,
trying to practice on my foot
machines with this machines,
with jeans, with Fifth
Street. I don't care, but
a fireable haters
that you can't tell me you don't like,
you know,
a little bit of joy that I can tell. He's
like, if Dj Khaled was actually dumber,
so we knew it would
happen. We get, we get of
all the podcasts, the most amazing
song submission. So last week, oh,
that was made specifically for your show?
No, no, no, no. So, but we know that like,
whenever we play, like, you know, like
we play like she's retarded clip. Yeah.
Like someone will make a song out of
that and like some of them are legit song
production people,
you
know,
they'll just,
there we go.
Here we go.
She said sort of classic
terminator. Yeah. Got It. Yeah,
yeah, yeah, sure.
Yeah.
So that was got to Yaddo tuned them
those came in. I've been having machines
within, it's stuck in my head. Oh,
last with ready. Catchy though. Right?
That's just like a vibrator store. Yeah.
It, uh, it's incredible. And
more machines within came in.
Here's a gun. Yeah. Nadir Gun.
Let's see what this one is here.
Wow.
This is the Max.
Incredible.
That's amazing.
This is a, by the way, this is
sounds good.
Genes within metal by machine
genes
play made a real,
there was a bit like he
put a band together and
no. So what happens is like,
okay, so for like the first few,
what happened was people took the audio
that we played with this guy walking
down the street, just got machines
within and they created, uh,
a song out of that. In other words,
they, they looped in beats and then they,
and they made a song out of it.
This one right here,
I don't know if on that one right there,
they actually sang it themselves or
whether they distorted it or not.
I don't know. It's pretty. And,
but like this guy right here
just submitted this also.
So here's a little different
take on machines. I mean,
it's going to be the full corrosion
on it. A big fans. So you got,
so Tom and Cindy, um, and
it was an amazing time.
We kept seeing machines within all day.
So I just kind of like in my head.
So hope you enjoy it.
Yep.
Oh,
I was right.
Good.
Jesus.
That's amazing.
That's by Kyle. She's
by Kyle. So good haters.
Half all the haters and
wow. Impressive man. Those
guys inspiring people
had I know is going to be fun.
That,
that's amazing. That's my pick. And
they both work. Yeah. That's the thing.
These guys found a way to make the song
work. It's all about the producer man.
Gotta find your deep. Do you guys
put out an album once a year? No.
Let's do a Christmas
production.
The second guy stalling
before an oral exam.
This is a
what's jeans? What's fake?
Dj Meet farts. Unbelievable.
What talent he to meet parts
has a good little sound system.
Yeah.
That [inaudible] is the terminator.
Yeah, of course. He didn't know that.
Uh,
so somebody wrote in,
my husband's steward is an avid
listener of your mom's house.
He listens while working hate came home.
The day machines within episode was
played. It's always been singing.
The song is stuck in my head.
I haven't listened to it.
It's hard to get down
and dirty and disease.
Ms And ms teams within is
all I'm hearing beforehand.
As a previous writer submitted that
juggler has tapped into something and my
husband and now I'm afraid of my husband
is a kid gonna convert to juggle.
Oh awesome. You guys are an awful
influence to my 27 year old husband.
Much love Christy Christy.
It's infected all of us.
If I do kill multiple people,
that will be when I'm,
do you want to know something? That
guy posted another video of a new song
much. No. Hey, great.
For Halloween,
I am the mass murderer. I may him
mashed murder. My Song is called,
it's a mass murder of the grave.
Oh so far.
Mass
murderer of the grave.
The mass murderer of the grave of the
grave as can be mass murder of the gray
was can be mass murder and makes me
no, it's great. In joke writing,
you really got to make your premise
clear and that's what he does with songs.
He's like, Chris rock really sets
it up. Yup. Here's what the song's
about. For people that
aren't watching. He has,
he has blood on his face and his clothes.
I mean might have bury the lead on that.
I know we did leave that out
because we're like just got that.
A lot of blood on his face
because we're like,
this is
mass murderer on the map to the
grave from the grave to the grave.
Mass murder from the [inaudible],
from the gray mass murder from the grant.
Ra is going to be defending this guy soon.
Yasmar from the grave.
I'm chopping the burst
mass murderer makes me cool.
Mass murderer makes me cool.
Yeah. Mass murderer makes me
cool. Cooler can be Muslim.
No pain, no pain. It sounded like coolest.
Oh my God. How is it
possible? This guy is too.
Yeah.
Deep down.
Deep down in the grave
spiritually from the grieve.
I wouldn't agree. Spearfishing
from hell. Hell, hell is chaos.
Do you think you could do live?
Do you think you'd do a live show?
I think if you could book him as
your opener is what you're saying.
I mean like do you think it could
handle it? It's a good five minutes.
That's a solid five. Try to get
him to shut up. Once you're on
stage though.
Seven mass
rave as can already sent it in. It's a
merger of the great. How did they hear it?
Did you play this in a previous episode?
Somebody found this video makes
me and made the song murder,
but then next,
next episode people will have made
much more on rave mass murder.
Mass murder from the grave.
Here we go. Here we go.
Mass murder from the paper mache mermaids
me. Cool. Mass murder makes me cool. Yeah.
Mass murderer makes me
cool as can be Muslim.
No hate. Must love new. Hey mass murder.
That is a no chase with that song.
Thank you know chase.
Thanks everybody is sending in
your machines within remixes.
Those were really good. Looking forward
to, she's retarded songs next week.
They're really good. This guy does
have a gift for the idea though.
I'm saying this Juggalos.
Yeah,
he does have a gift of putting together
like silly things. Silly, catchy.
He could write jingles. Maybe you know he
could write for the insane clown posse.
Maybe that's quite a leap put on with
the, Jimmy wants his dick and that, oh,
Jimmy Ivy. No. Right.
Did you watch that? Um,
defiant ones on HBO about
Jimmy Iovine and Dr Dre.
Like a four [inaudible] it's so good,
man.
Their story, Jimmy, I've been story
is just bananas. It's so, it's, it's,
it's insane what like how he got into
being a record producer, you know,
he was like cleaning up a studio
for a job, like after hours,
like just mopping. Right. And then they're
like, do you know how to run a board?
Yeah. And he was like, no. And then
a guy shows them how to run a board.
That's amazing.
And it's just like,
and athlete like one thing into the
next and then he's sitting there like
engineering a Springsteen album. Wow.
And then, uh, he tells a story about it.
That's right. Yes. He talks about it. This
book. It's wild. Yeah. And then how about,
uh, I think it was Ivan. He's Catholic
and it was like an Easter where there,
one of the guys was like, you need to
come that we need you to hear today.
He's like, it's Easter Sunday. And the
guy was like, fucking come to the studio.
And his family was like, come on, you're
not leaving on this. He's, he's young.
He's like in his early 20. [inaudible]
and he goes in and it's for, uh,
it's a Lennon session. Wow.
Yeah. So he's sitting there like,
he's like, I just said Fuck
Easter. Yeah. And just, he was a,
Oh, that's amazing. He
didn't know. He just went in.
He was telling me to come in and do
one in. Yeah. Damn, that's the thing.
I always tell young people now that you
hit a certain age and you talked to a
lot of young people about, you know,
everybody wants advice. And we went and,
and it's, it's hard because if you catch
me on a bad day, and this has happened,
I've taught kids out of
going into show business,
my friend Tom asked me to
talk to his son, um, and, uh,
he wanted to go into comedy writing
and I read his scripts and it was okay.
It was okay. And in this business,
it's got to not just be good.
It's gotta be excellent. And it's gotta
be original. There has to be like,
you know, like somebody, a SPEC script,
it gets traction in this town is like
somebody will take a partridge family
episode from 1971 and
then they'll put in uh,
isis as like, you have to come
up with shit. That's crazy.
And then on top of it be so well written
and so, and I just said to him, I go,
look man, you got a college degree. Does
just, there's so many other things to do.
And his father who's black got really
upset with me. He's like, dude,
what did you fucking tell my son? And I
was like, I'm sorry man. It was a bad day.
It was a bad day for them.
I totally get that. I, you
know what I did once this is,
I mean like I don't think
I did the wrong thing.
I picked the wrong time was I told a
comic who was booked by a club that was
emceeing to not do so much crowd work.
Oh that,
well I told him cause he was doing
it every show. Yeah. And, um,
it was like Saturday between the first
and late show where I go, look, man, I go,
someone's going to tell you, someone's
going to tell you this at some point.
And like, you should know that like when
you're on a headliner show like this,
like you really don't,
it shouldn't be up to you to just
decide to do 10 minutes of crying.
And he was like, what? And I
go, I'm telling you this to, uh,
to be rude, but like you're,
you're basically dictating that.
Like that's the tone of what
they're about to see. You're not,
you're actually making it,
it's not even really fucking up my show,
but it's like the Middle Act, who on
this hierarchy is definitely above you,
is now like putting this thing where he's
like, has to adapt to your crowd. Right.
Exactly. Not only that, now
you meet you in the feature.
I'd have to watch him every shell to
see you so you don't talk to the same
people he's talking.
It's, so I, I did it in
like a nice way. Yeah.
But man that he was shell shocked
and I couldn't tell right away.
He went up there and bombed. And
then afterwards, like, you know, I,
I didn't say much to him after his set,
but after the show he was like,
I go,
dude,
like somebody was going to tell you that
and they might not have even been as
nice about it as I was. I said, well,
you think you can just get on like
fucking bill birds show and just be like,
Ma, I'm just going to do
fucking Crowdwork. Yeah,
go, you can't do that shit.
And he was like, really? I go, it's not
like this was like a showcase thing.
Do what you want, you know, was
20 comics going up? Fine. They go,
but like this is not that show.
This is a weekend show. And um,
he was like, ah, I guess,
you know, I just, um,
I guess you telling me like two minutes
before I went up Kinda threw me off was
like, sorry, I felt bad.
I felt bad about the timing
of it. I was like, yeah,
it's powerful for a young comic
to hear from a, you know a legend.
Yeah. Yeah. Will you go, will you tell,
especially if you tell him like right,
if someone tells you something,
right. There was, I was,
well I,
I always do this thing when I'm on the
road and I don't know when I started
doing it,
but every time the MC and sometimes I,
I've met the emcee for two
enough to get my, my intro,
cause if it's the first night,
I just haven't spent time with them
and I always will go. He'll go,
Greg Fitzsimmons and I come up
and then when he shakes your hand,
when he walks off, I
was go, thanks faggot.
And then I do my set and
I never talk about it.
And then the next time I go up I'll go,
thanks homo.
And I just keep saying thanks cock sucker.
And I do it each time and
they never bring it up.
And then this one guy comes up to me
Saturday night between shows. He's like,
he goes, did I do something?
Goes did I do, did I go long?
I keep thinking that I did that bit.
That's similar to yours and his,
did that make you mad? He,
he was going through and what
I would, it could be. I go,
no dude, I do that to everybody. I never,
I never imagined anybody would
take it as anything, but it's,
yeah, of course, of course. I can
imagine though, if you're that guy,
the anxiety he probably had the
next day. He was probably like,
I thought it was a good show,
but I can tell me me a faggot,
it's done. He goes,
there's a, cause that guy,
I was doing crowd work with that guy and
I kinda like backed down and I thought
that maybe that's why you kept calling
me that and it's like I didn't have the
heart to tell him. I didn't
watch all of his sets, you know?
Oh man, that's the other one is when they,
um, sometimes they are like Saturday,
the be like, you see the set and I
go, no, not once. That's a whole week.
You guys are terrible people.
And then I'm like, I just, I,
I can't do it then.
I don't want to watch.
It's hard because sometimes if I
watch the feature and he's got,
he's got a bit that's
really close to mind.
It depresses me because I realize this
kid is in Oklahoma and he's a feature and
he and we're thinking the same joke.
So I don't even care if we repeat a
similar joke like I used to watch so I
didn't repeat a joke and now he just
figured it's more detrimental to even know
through that comedy is this easy
and I think it's so hard. Right?
And then you're like that
guy's name when that good.
I know that too where you're
like that's one of my,
that's a good as an original thought
or thought at the time. Like damn.
And I found when lightning in a bottle,
it's depressing.
I thought it went today actually when I
was on the toilet and I wrote it on my
phone,
which is Yelp is essentially
like you can tell a lot,
cause I was yelping um,
hot water heaters.
We need a new hot water heater and you
just see the range of opinions that
people can have about a piece
of hardware and that you know,
you know any given case a factory worker
didn't put a nut on or didn't it so it
doesn't make the company evil,
it just means that there's a variance in
quality of thanks but it becomes like a
roar shack test for the person that's
doing the reviewing and it's always like
this hot water heater makes me feel
lonely and someone else is like this thing
gets me laid as true.
So I want to put really innocuous things
on Yelp and just see how people like
friendship see on people.
How do you yell at Friends House?
That's true because it
is one big projection.
Your experience of something and like
the particular form of rejection and you
can always look for the
negative and something or you
can look for the positive.
Yeah,
we've been up by the way we've emailed,
we put out there a bunch of
these questions originally
we put out I think like
how to, what blind people
know when they're done wiping.
And then blind people would write
in and tell us how to deaf people.
Wake up in the morning.
And then last week we asked about
how to cop a lot of dumb questions.
Just trying to see now how do
cops, um, handcuff a one arm guy?
Like when they have a one arm guy,
here's your answer. We
go, we got the answer.
Hey Mommy's,
I'm a police officer on the east coast.
I'm explaining to you how
to cuff on one arm. PERP.
First option is to cut off one
hand and put the other cuff off,
cuff off one hand,
put the other cuff on a belt loop
on the opposite side of their genes.
If they're foolishly not wearing
their jeans high and tight,
then they just get cuffed to a
stationary, immovable object. Thanks.
And the Canadian answer and I didn't
know we had a different answer there.
Their hand,
uh, the police. Okay.
On your recent Potty,
I heard you ask police how to handcuff
someone with one. On one hand,
I'm a police officer in Canada and
recently helped arrest a one handed man.
No Way. The short answer to
the question is we can't.
One would assume that you can just
cut his one hand directly to ankle.
So apartment Paulison specifically
prohibits this because it is considered a
hard time and can cause fat people with
respiratory problems and stop breathing.
We are issued nylon Rhett leg restraints,
however they are useless
if the rest of the person,
if the arrested person is also is not
handcuff because they can just bend over
and take them.
The only restraints that we
consider acceptable or the
metal shackles that would
cut his cough is hand to the front and
have as a long chain reaching around down
to the ankles. They're
loosely cuff together. Patrol
cops don't carry shackles,
so we just shoved him
into the back of the van.
I hope this helps and thanks
for the great podcast, Justin.
Well thank you both Brim Lau and
Justin for the snappy in one armed and
overweight. Oh, like it couldn't
get worse. And committing crimes,
you're just like being in your arrested
just like your life is just shit.
You know, you're in jail, you're
fat and you got one arm. Yeah,
I was watching Trudeau on the
Internet, you know, they're,
you know that Canadian band,
the tragically hip. Yeah.
It's like Canon is pride.
Right.
And the lead singer died.
And here's like sweet ass Trudeau
crying about this lead singer.
Did you see him buying Shannon
couldn't love them anymore. Yeah.
He was like national treasure.
And I was like,
imagine if Donald Trump like our stupid
president book bunch of faggots crying
about some bad, get it together. Yeah.
Like, oh my God, what a difference.
And I know he's got an military guys
go down and he doesn't even take it
seriously.
I see that thing this,
this morning,
how brutal where the widow of the of
the soldier that died was on like good
morning America. And she
was like, yeah, that,
that account that Frederica Wilson gave
of how the president spoke is spot on.
That's where I'm like, God. And He,
and she was what made me really sad.
It was that he,
he couldn't remember my husband's
name and he immediately tweeted,
I spoke to her and I'd
never hesitated about him,
his name from the very beginning, like
he tweeted that immediately. Oh boy.
I mean, the amazing thing is there was a
witness to the first call. So number one,
what's the agenda of a fallen soldier?
His parents to lie about the
president of United States. Right.
And then you've got corroboration
from a congress woman,
not just Johnny, you know, she had had
in the back of the van, like, yeah,
no, for this woman, she was on the
call. It was speakerphone, her aunt,
her uncle, the congresswoman and the
driver. So five people. Yeah. And she's,
and she's like, nope. And
he's like, that's not what
happened out of that. Yeah.
It's crazy.
Wow.
It's true.
That's not even your priority to call
out the president at that moment when it
all started,
because he was taking shots
at Obama saying that I,
he didn't use to call me
while Obama called every one
of them followed up with a
letter and usually called back
six months later. So why go after,
first of all, it's like,
it's like a lawyer says,
don't ask a question.
You don't know the answer to.
Don't Attack Obama on something that
you don't know the answer to. Yeah.
Especially when you're actually
guilty of it yourself. Yeah. Well,
he's a sociopath. It's crazy. It's
banana. She just ban ban Trump.
Talk from all podcast.
Let's try it.
We gotta we to go on.
Oh,
this dental update is
brought to you by quip Q.
U. I. P. You don't need a big, expensive
toothbrush to get the oral care you need.
Get the same refreshing,
clean with something simpler
that'll give you the most,
the best brushing experience you've ever
had. The words exciting and toothbrush.
I've literally never been used
in the same sentence until now.
Introducing quip,
the new company.
That's refreshing the way
people brush their teeth.
Quip is an electric toothbrush that packs
premium vibration and timer features
into an ultra slim design that that's
half the cost of bulkier brushes.
It's basically like apple designed a
toothbrush, but without the big price tag,
you have to see it and brush with
it to experience it yourself.
You can even subscribe to receive
new brush heads on a dentist.
Recommended three month
plan for just $5 a month.
Fluting it's awesome.
Free Shipping.
Quip is backed by leading dentist and
was named as one of Time Magazine's best
inventions of 2016 they want a 2016 GQ
grooming award and made it on Oprah's
2017 new year's o list.
Quip starts at just $25 that is a
fraction of what these other electric
toothbrushes go for right now.
Go to quip,
get quip.com g e t Q u I p.com/mom to
get your first refill pack free with a
quip electric toothbrush.
That's your first refill pack.
free@getquipdotcomslashmomgetquip.com
slash m o.
M. Thank you quip. So Greg,
we're big dental fans here.
We like knowing what's going on inside
people's mouths. I'd like to know,
have you been to the dentist recently? Did
you brush and floss? Floss reason? Yeah.
Say the wisdom tooth is not here. Yeah.
Got it out five days ago, five days ago.
Why is the gallery then he
I think it was that day. No.
Yeah. What? Yeah. What like it
didn't bother me. Didn't bother me.
Before we get to the
sale of this, how are you a regular like
are, are you good at oral care, do you
I floss every day,
thank God because I've got a couple
of niches in between my that just,
they just fill up. I eat anything. I've
got something in those, in those spots.
It drives me crazy and so I love
the little handheld flossing
devices. Those, they don't
like that. I like them.
I keep those in my bag and
then I floss every night.
I brush at least three times a day.
I'm consumed with having bad breath
because when people have bad breath,
I can't hang out with them anymore.
Dude,
it's ruined a few like people
that I want to hang out with. Yes.
It's all I think about your breath.
One of them,
like I like a friend and I'm
just like, I dunno. It's weird.
Like I can't write that off.
We both wrote down three names
of comedians with bad breath.
They would crossover. I bet. I
bet. At least let's do that. Okay.
When we're off the air.
Um, so, uh, anyway,
so I go in and I was feeling this pain
when I bite on the right side of my mouth.
And so I went in and the, and, and I swear
war. And how often do you go to the
dentist? Do you go regularly? Yeah,
go once a year. Okay. Okay. And uh, oh,
I take my teeth very seriously. Yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
You know, it's very,
you'd be surprised because I only
ask because of the range of like,
some people come in here or they'll
email in and they'll be like,
haven't been to the dentist in 10 years.
And then they go, because you guys talk.
But all the time I just decided
to go and we get the full range.
Some people were like, I had 26 cavities.
Right. And some people were like,
you wouldn't believe what I haven't been
in 10 years. Nothing. Yeah, I'm fine.
Right. Anyway, I have very hard teeth. I
didn't get a lot of cavities in my life.
My mom's got hard teeth. We don't get
cavities. Wow. They're very white.
Is that a natural?
I don't know.
I used toothbrush with the white neuron
it and maybe like know smile. Oh Wow,
this one's fake. This got knocked out.
Ooh. And Aah. And they've put it in.
And that was when I was 15 and it's still
going strong ground on the last that
long. Now what about veneer work?
Porcelain? No, nothing like that. No.
Bondings of any kind of, wow. So you're,
you're feeling a pain though. So I'm
feeling a pain when I bite and I'm
convinced it's my second molar top. Uh,
uh, right. Yup. And so
I go in and the guy, uh,
takes, takes a, like a cue tip and he
says, bite down and keep biting down.
I'm not feeling the pain.
And it keeps going.
And then he goes back to the
wisdom tooth and I bite on that.
And there was the pain.
And so it was like this phantom thing
where I thought it was this tooth,
but it was the other one. So then he
goes, all right, well, you know, we can,
we can, uh, he says, he, I
think it's cracked. He said,
and so because I,
I do to have filling in that one.
And so the wall of it was too
thin. So he goes, all right,
we're going to pull it next week.
And so I go home and then that week
I'm chewing and all sudden I chew on
something hard.
And it was the outside piece of the
wisdom tooth had fallen off and I crunched
down. And here's the amazing
thing about the human tooth.
A dental system,
you will be biting full speed.
What does that 20 miles an hour each bite.
Sure.
And then if something
is in there that's hard.
Your teeth stop in a nano
millimeter for crushing down.
Isn't that incredible?
And it just stops. Yeah.
And even when you're
fat, it's about, and so,
uh, so I went in and he, uh,
he went in to pull it out and
he shot me with the Nova Cane.
And all I'm asking is in advance.
I'm like,
so can I get like a barbiturates or
whatever, can I, can I get some opioids?
And he's like, I don't think you'll
really need it. And I'm going, you know,
I'm pretty pain sensitive
and I'm really not, but, uh,
I want to get them and give
them to my friends. And so, uh,
and so he goes in and he's like,
gives me the penicillin shot and that not
penicillin. The, uh, the numbing thing,
the Novocaine, Novocaine, and
then, and then he's picking her,
he's poking around and then all of
a sudden he holds it in front of me.
It took like three minutes.
He just popped it right
out and then, um, you know,
gave me some gauze to chew on and
I did three shows at night. Oh,
Mike with the gauze in my mouth.
Oh, here, here in la. And then I,
and then I went out the next
day. Took the, you know,
said the gauze out overnight.
The next day I was,
I was fine and I haven't had any pain.
Some people get wisdom teeth out
and for whatever reason it's, oh,
it's an leads.
It affected and they have pain from
back then when I,
when I had mine taken out,
they weaved in some cloth
that had a painkiller,
but it had a clove clover,
clover
and I,
I absolutely cannot stand it.
So I would driving around like,
oh, and tasting the clothes,
the clove tastes. Yeah. And I
had to, I called, I was like,
you have to put something else in.
Like I'm going to, I'm going to be not,
I'm going to throw up. And so I had
to go in, they had to weave it back,
put another one in. Wow. I never have,
I've never heard this story 12 years.
And I never,
you know about your dental history time.
I know you always get something exciting
and fun with a dental update or you do
a dental update on every episode that
every episode we've probably done,
I don't know, 50 of, I mean we'd
like to, it's funny like we,
we aligned with this company where we're
both there like trying to make oral
care more a part of the conversation
and we naturally did this,
been doing this for years. Like we just
bring it up because I think we're just,
I know it started as a joke.
It was started as a joke.
I had put the veneer stuff
or some dental work done. No,
I had a crown replaced.
My point is that we were so boring to
talk about on the podcast that we made it
a segment on the point of
fascination. Yeah. In other words,
and it really is interesting to
hear people's take on it. Like it's,
it's so extreme, but there are people
who come sit here and are like,
don't brush, don't do anything. And
you're, yeah. It's just, I don't know.
It's like one of those things that you
take for granted that someone is probably
going to take care of it.
Oh well it is like old people.
One of the first things they'll
tell you is take care of your teeth.
Cause when you get old in,
that shit starts popping out or in pain.
I've asked, I always ask whenever I go
to any type of medical professional,
as soon as you get that rapport going
with like the nurse, I'm always like,
tell me some wild shit. Like what?
What? And they told me that like, I go,
what's the craziest thing you
see here in the dentist's office?
And they're always like, oh, it's
old people who have neglected.
Do you think it smells
bad when they said no?
Some of them will tilt their head back
and there was just food packed. Yeah.
Oh,
goals and in between. And I'm
like, and the smell of be like,
it's not describable smell.
It's a,
it's the most nauseating
thing you've ever seen
and you got to get it.
And then the dentist assistant has to
get in there with the floss and floss,
go out
being a dental hygienist.
Could you even imagine the smells and
you're working for a suicidal boss,
number one suicide rate.
Why do they want to kill themselves?
But no one wants to be there as monotonous
and people are afraid when they up
there. I mean, I catch myself in
the chair and I go, oh my God,
every muscle in my body is
tense right now. Right. And
they pick up on that. Yeah.
As opposed to being a comedian where what,
how fucking great is our job.
People come in, they drink,
they relax, they, and,
and it's also like, I was thinking about
this, like, we're not that good. Right.
What we do is not that good because we
learn over time to be calm and act like
we know what we're doing.
But the truth is those two or 300
people are sitting there with an agenda.
Yeah. They are there to laugh.
It's like when you go to a, uh,
a sad movie, you're there to cry. I don't
cry when I go to it's sad movie. I cry.
Right. So when I go to a comedy show, it
doesn't matter how funny the person is,
I paid, you know, whatever
they're paying to get in 20 bucks,
25 bucks and two drinks, they're
fucking laughing. Right, right. Maybe,
but then again, there's the, the, I dare
you to make me laugh. People too. Yeah.
But that's not, most of us are most,
they're watching your specials like oh,
that's different. Some on TV
it's different. Yeah. Yeah.
And then it's a challenge.
Yes.
Yeah. The best was when you're getting
these notes, different dynamic.
The emails that I get, emails,
like I press play on your,
on your special knowing that it would suck
and you're, and you're like,
cool. And then they'll be like,
I gotta admit I did laugh and I
was totally not expecting too.
You're not, you're not as Shitty
as I thought you would be.
Like that's a very nice email.
And you know,
they think that they're being clever.
Yeah.
But it really is so annoying.
It's so those him emails or after shows
with some of the codes to go, hey,
you weren't that bad. It's like,
just walk. Just fucking walk away.
Yeah. Yeah. I always, I'm the one
that I always tell is like the, uh,
like they're like, you were pretty
funny and you're like, would you,
would you honestly walk up to another
human being and qualify a compliment like
that? Like, would you approach
a woman be like, yeah, you know,
you're not bad looking. Yeah.
You know, it's like the, the,
the way that you're saying that
is such a shitty tone to say like,
well,
it means that that guy probably sees
himself as the funniest guy in his office
and he can't give up the Alpha status.
That's really interesting. Yeah. I never,
I never thought of it that way.
There's a lot of alpha. Yeah. I mean,
we're assuming alpha status and
the same for you. Yeah. You know,
you're walking in and you're
saying that's why women do.
And one of the many theories
why women are, you know,
there's that thing of like women aren't
funny and it's all, it's like, well no,
it's that you won't give over
to the way I just described.
People walking into club and
sitting down and giving over.
I think there's a criteria for who
they will give it over to as well.
And for men they don't sell. You don't
want to give up their alpha status. Yeah.
It's a position of power to,
to hold a microphone and to be like,
you're listening to me for
the next hour of your life.
And also a women aren't
allowed to be loud, vulgar,
aggressive.
It's societaly frowned upon for a woman
to a assert that kind of power. Yeah.
So attractive. Sexually attractive. Yeah.
How threatened men are.
Um,
in all aspects of like on social media,
I was thinking about like all the shit
talking like all the hate. It's all dudes.
And I probably have a more,
obviously skew more male followers,
but like all the fucking hate all the
shit talking. It's all guys. Yeah.
It's all guys. It's like
unprompted. They're just
pushing their issues onto you.
Yeah. You know, it's like whatever,
they're attacking you for it.
Sometimes it's like, oh, you know,
you have this a nice fucking
shirt asshole and you're like,
what? Yeah. You know, or it's like,
yeah, you think you're so fucking funny.
What about some guy wrote me like I,
I did some sarcastic post and he was like
easy to say when you have success and
your wife has makes money and blah
blah blah. I'm like, yeah, right.
It's the grand post. Right.
I'm just joking. Although
when a woman criticizes me,
she's almost always dead on.
So it's like the thing you said it was
actually kind of racist we got, yeah.
Like think about it. You're right.
Yeah, you're right. That's true.
I know a lot of females criticizing
me now from the special,
it's a lot of female on female
eight. Really? Oh yeah. Yeah.
Maybe it's that the sexist feel
more comfortable criticizing.
They're all 100% yeah. Yeah. Cause guide
the, the, what I get from guys is like,
I usually hate a female comics, but
you're funny. Like a guy. He's funny.
And then I'm like, thanks. I think,
thank you. I don't know, you know,
like every other dumb broad out there.
Yeah. Good job. Wow. What a compliment.
Yeah. By the way, did you pick up
on this, uh, the David Cross thing?
Did you hear about this or read about it?
What happened?
How he was accused of being racist,
but like in a tweet,
oh, I saw that there was an Asian,
a comedic actress, Simon say,
and I don't want to give this person
any thunder. I mean, it's a known story.
I think that, you know, David
Cross is whole sensibility
is ironic. Every, I mean it's
like Sarah Silverman, it's a call.
Anything she says is racist is like split.
You don't get what this person is.
That's what I thought too, man. And the
other thing that I, I want to say like,
yeah,
we have to give some sense.
I mean, it's literally like
me calling that Guy Faggot
as being homophobic. Right?
When I say to the MC,
like that's literally how add a
context that would be David Cross.
So the story of people know is that the,
the comedic actress was,
I think, I think it was at a bar in,
on location before shooting a movie.
This is how I understand it.
And like people are getting together at
the bar and that he approached and she
said that he was like,
um,
he said something to her and she
was like stunned by what she, yeah.
He made fun of her pants or
something. Yeah. And then he was like,
you know how to speak English
and then challenged her to a karate
fight. And I was like, yeah, I, you know,
I just thought like, but if
you're, cause you're a comp,
if the person who was saying
it was, is a comedian, yeah.
Don't you think that like if you know
David Cross that he is actually playing,
like playing the part of
that stupid person, right.
In an improvisational moment.
Right. Like that's how I was like,
wouldn't that be like automatic?
It's a compliment that he would think
that you'd be okay with it. Right, right.
Great. 100%. Yeah. Um, and I
just felt like, I don't know,
I mean I'm not Asian so I don't have the
right to like say whether or not it's
offensive, but I'm like, but I am a
comic. And I'm like, yeah. Like if,
if he came up to me and started like
doing what David Cross does and like
jumping into like a
character and insulting me.
Like that's supposed to be the fun thing
that you're like, yeah, oh yeah man.
Like your yes and it, yeah, yeah,
yeah. You go along with it. Sure.
And to recount it 10 years later and
be like, God, that was so painful.
It just sounded like,
I was like,
oh, you're so weak. It might.
Well that's the problem now with the whole
me to pound sign me too Hashtag yeah.
Is that it's so undefined and it's such
an excuse for anybody to just bitch
about feeling slighted at some point.
Feeling slighted and being sexually
harassed are very different things. Yeah.
Well racial, racially harassed. The
whole problem is the non specificity,
specificity. Specificity. For instance,
if you're going to call someone a racist
and you're going to do it on Twitter
and 150 characters or less like is that
really fair to put someone on blast in
two sentences? The answer is no racism.
You know, like to tell that story
like we met at the bar before,
like you know as a like as a cast and
then like to take all the nuance out of
the conversation.
Yes.
And then that was racist to me.
Well it's also a misuse of the
word racist because racism is
the, the, the,
the person who has the power using that
power to objectify or oppress the person
of another race. Geez. The lesser race,
the superior race acting
superior basically is a crime.
We earned it. Yeah. Look,
we only fucked within our thin
gene pool for thousands of years,
so we could be better.
But I mean,
but I mean racism is the
acting out of a prejudice.
Yeah. So just making it up. Not even say,
say David Cross was it for
the most liberal outspokenly,
you know,
democratic guy.
If he say this in one moment of
his life decided to be a racist,
he didn't do anything about it.
He didn't keep her from
getting an a movie or on stage.
So there's no crime and I think
he is one of the most liberal, uh,
he is like really? He and his
wife have followed them on
Instagram. Yeah. Ps sweet.
I doubt that.
And what the Hashtag me too think I'd
like to know what the stories are.
I feel like if it, if it's not
specific, it's like what is,
how is this helping people? Yeah.
There you go. Cause in sharing stories,
that's how people help each other. Do
you know what an Asian woman by the way,
making fun of another Asian.
She was no, she, this woman
is actually talking about how,
how she said that like uh,
that she'll fight your ass even
though I'll let her say it so
fucked up bitch, I'm still hurting
shit and we'll fuck your is stop. Okay.
You want to fuck with my money?
Oh, I fucking love that. So
Schatz a character, she's a,
she's a real hood ass chick, right? What
does she look like? She's, um, I guess,
I think it was she Chinese,
Vietnamese, and um, but she like,
uh, from New York and talks
like, like super ghetto.
And then it goes, she was like, oh, I
might look like I'll change, I'll bow.
Fuck your ass up. He want to fuck
with my mind. Who I fuck with me?
Do you want to fuck with me man?
Oh,
that's be as Vietnamese,
right?
Yeah. May, may, may, may
is her name. I don't know.
I'm on my mind.
Yeah.
The Vietnamese gangs are bad ass.
They were no tourists when they started
coming over here and like the 90s,
I forget why they was like an
influx of Vietnamese gangs and, uh,
the cops would talk about how, you know,
it all started with like, you know,
the Italian mobsters. Right. And
that mafia were really, they just,
they killed other fat guys. There
wasn't, there wasn't too much.
And then along came
like, um, you know, uh,
inner city crips and bloods and
they were killing other bystanders.
Got killed a lot. But then these
Vietnamese gangs came along and they said,
these motherfuckers were scary than any
of the other gangs because these guys
would just black fucking open fire there
we do is all kinds of hits going on.
And, and they said they were,
they were really fucking tough.
And then of course the Russians came.
Oh savages that just like Trump
everyone. And then, you know,
I remember when we were kids,
like the big thing when I was growing up,
my mother's Peruvian is
we would always refer,
everyone would referred to the
Colombians as like the most savage. Yeah,
no cause it like the cartels and
they're like, they're so violent.
And then they were definitely,
I mean they look like
fucking kindergarteners
next to the Mexican cartels.
So much way more savagery and the Mexican
cartels like fucking will kill a whole
kid,
like a school full of kids and all the
teachers and stab notes into them so that
when the cops come, the notes are
stabbed into the kid's dead bodies.
No Shit. Yeah. Yeah.
Because like they were trying to
oppress the cartel in that area. Wow.
Crazy shit like that. You
know, it's like in um, way,
but I'm saying like leftover.
Yeah. You know what?
Well,
it's like member apocalypse now and when
at the end he's talking about how the
Americans would send a medical units in
to try to treat the Vietnamese who had,
I forget what disease they have,
but they gave him shots of penicillin
and then the warlords would come in and
they would chop off the
children's arms that got the shot.
And then that's when Marlon
Brando said the horror, AH,
Jesus Christ
gray matter.
It's all made a song out of that.
It is a good song.
My mind.
Ah,
Tuesday
I belie
man my day because I make crazy as videos
in my hair. Fucking Matt, come
on, look was talking to you too.
Your Dick in a box to tick,
tick,
tick, tick, tick,
tick in the wrong.
You remember a
great,
yeah, it's really good. I can't stand when
somebody comment under one of my video.
It's too high. No
waterfall. But I am blessed.
Uh,
so this guy last week tried to tell us,
tell the Internet that if
you want to feel Horny,
you should take 10 to 12 Benadryl.
You're going to answer
by when you see this one,
he's a die.
If you take 12 where
we thought crazy person. Yeah. He's like,
you want to be a horny 10 to 12 Benadryl.
Send me the hospital
before you have sex.
Do you want to be horny for two or three
hours? Like you never been in your life?
Any of access to marijuana too good.
We'd listen to me.
She came to me.
True wheat alone can get your
really hornier than normal,
but it's been on general.
Take about 10 12 billion girl before you
want to have your sexual fun with your
partner or whatever you do or masturbate.
All right,
so this guy,
I'm thinking it's the ladder with him.
This guy is often in the balloon.
Odd. He's, he's, he's real. He's the,
they send them some more videos of him,
so he's gone for it.
He's really going for it.
But this person said that's one way
I heard the most recent podcasts.
It needed to share. When I was
in high school, Somebody told me,
you took a bunch of Benadryl. It
would give you a pleasant, hi,
I'm not sure what is wrong with that
women's wrestling guy because it was truly
one of the worst, worst
experiences in my life. And movies.
They often show acid and mushrooms is
terrifying, inducing terrifying visuals,
which they don't for most
people, unfortunately. This
is exactly what happened.
Most of them, I felt like it was on
fire. I could not tell what was real,
what wasn't.
I was talking to people I believed were
there and I would look back and they
were gone.
When I would walk into a different room,
I would think I was somewhere else
on a different day. Towards the end,
I was chasing it.
Tarantula around the room and
trying to kill it with a broom says,
considering this guy has done this a lot,
he must be a special kind of crazy.
Keep your dosage is low when experimenting
with drugs or new masturbation
techniques. Dr Lee's, I bet he
didn't sneeze one style. Yeah.
See upside on the bright
side. You this, uh,
could you imagine this guy's fucked up?
Well,
can you imagine watching the
video and then going, I'll
try it. Yeah. Look at this.
I mean there's,
you're talking about take the,
this is the string from his shorts.
Obviously it goes to my pants right now,
but
cause hard as you can to rip this apart.
Close hers.
You can you fill those magnets,
a little atomic magnets that make
molecules and the molecules stick down our
molecules. No, no they don't.
That's a magnet.
Lots of the little pity magnets ma'am.
He also turns out he's really
pissed off at women in general.
I know why.
I was going to say,
I mean when I see a waste
of human existence like
that and you think about how
much work it took for his mommy to
make him and care and then you're like,
no, this is what you're
fucking dealing with your
life. You've suck. All right. Well
all M and are the reason that I'm done.
I take fucking 30
Benadryl at once at night.
Third fucking want to get horny
and enjoy myself sexually without,
and then there's the jealousy and rage
as you I have over. Even Lesbians,
I'm jealous of you even so.
See,
but you get to be horny or in grow up
sexually and mature sexually because
you've had real pussy in your face.
And I haven't.
I got to get he watching the
fucking videos on youtube.
I spent thousands of dollars in my life.
I'm female wrestling and little
girls do that all the time, man.
And Post it on Youtube and it's more fun
and it's free, but the fucking sucks.
The quality and everything else.
There's little girls. God Damn
No, I think he's saying he
watches female wrestling. Yeah.
And that any chick woman can do this,
make that video her,
grab her friend. We can get all the pussy
in the world. He's saying, but he can't.
So he's jealous. Yeah, no,
that's true. He hates his mommy.
Nice. Your sexuality.
America fucking sucks.
What these guys are
talking about in America.
Have you ever left America and shot of
a woman there? A better place for you?
Yeah.
In America.
Yeah. It's America's fault. Yeah.
Yeah. He doesn't have a passport.
Never left the town that he's from.
He also thinks it's really stupid.
Like it's really lame to want
to have traditional sex. Oh Wow.
What?
I have never in my life wanting to stick
my dick inside of a woman and calm.
That is the stupidest, nasty as
dumb ass thing I've ever had. To me.
It's no different almost.
And having sex with a gun in the ass hole,
which is disgusting as fuck,
too.
Option three years.
Those are the holes.
What's going on?
Fuck. I would never, so my, my is tried
to get me to watch regular porn. Like
when your porn and your,
the way you make out in your stupid
boring fucking bullshit. Yeah.
Fucking all of your own.
Buy Your woman.
You're all a bunch of
fucking pieces of shit.
Oh God doesn't love you and you are you
any more. You're fucked. Oh my goodness.
Honey. Here I am on the planet
with your mother fucker.
Hmm hmm. Have a good
day, mother fucker. Ah,
so my mom used to say when she threatened
me. Oh yeah. Have a nice fucking day,
which she really, yeah,
she like threatened me.
Horrible letters to me and then be like,
have a nice fucking,
it's a real crazy person's
thing. New Deal. Delia,
I didn't realize that last one by the
way is solidified the level that that
dude's really well you think? Well I mean
the 10 or 12 bandage rolls inside. Yeah.
Did you did not doubt it. But that
would the end there when he was like,
fuck you motherfucker.
Like that's that.
Is this guy not stumble onto
Methodist point? I know,
right? Good. 30 Benadryl. Okay.
Yeah. I think the next
step is meth. Yeah. I think
that's the step before this.
Like that's an old step.
He said it hard to get, Benadryl
is not like a controlled substance.
I know like sue DEF Sudafed is to
deference in there. Whatever happened
when I met her, you know everyone's
always like, wait til you meet my mom.
Like that kind of thing. She was
like, wait til you meet my mom please.
And then we met at a restaurant and she
was like, hello. And then she's like,
I was at Bloomingdale's. And he's fucking
cunt sales woman. And I was like, ah.
I started laugh so hard because
I was so funny. And she's like,
barely. She's like barely registering
me. She's like watching me laugh.
And she's like, I said, fuck you, you
fucking bitch. And I was like, oh wow.
First meeting we were in a
public restaurant or restaurant,
she would frequent and she would always
get the back booth so that people
couldn't hear her, so she
could really unleash. Yeah.
And then Christina was like,
when she was like, what are
her views on race? Super.
My mother was super racist. She
would, um, she felt slighted by that.
We went to a Sushi bar once
and they sat us in her opinion,
very close to the restroom,
which not really,
but she was too close to the toilet.
And so she got mad at the
waitress and she was like,
this fucking goop bitch set me near
the fucking toilet. Fuck fucker.
You're fucking gook.
And I was like, oh. Um,
so then we like got up and stormed out
and I had to follow her. I was like,
something's wrong. Jesus.
She was always right.
And my step father was Indian and
he was racist too. Ironically,
they're both dead now,
but that's one of my favorite,
like the psychology of like
these fucking immigrants,
like your Indian step immigrated at like
25 or 30 like a grown man came to this
country and was like, we gotta put these
border wall. Like he was like, yeah, pro.
You know what I mean? Like he
probably came in illegally. No, no,
he fought in our military.
Well he did and he came in legally,
but he was a republican and he gave a
lot of money to the Republican Party and
therefore felt that he was kind of
like, you know, like a white guy by,
by money. And he kind of
was like, in this country,
your economic status determines a
lot, right. How people perceive you.
And he was a baller, so
yeah. Oh Wow. That's crazy.
But pictures of the five last Republican
presidents sign personally given to him
because that's how much money,
he don't know what the party shit.
What did he do for work?
Oh really?
One answer that I'm a little bit a
little bit of everything and they say,
well, this little, it was little, my uh,
one of my friends growing up, not
that this means it, but it's probably,
it was Dominican and they, they were
like, I was like, what does your dad do?
They live, they were very wealthy and
import, export, import x. That's another,
it's like four years later it's like,
well what does he do specifically
import export. I'm like,
could you tell me what he,
and mostly important
distribution. Yeah. I was
like, hmm, okay. That was it.
That was the most you ever got spending
the night at his house. What do you do?
Import. Export, right. Yeah. Okay.
Well that's amazing because when you
think about a World War II and the people
that came over you, or even
going back to, you know,
the turn of the 19th century when people
came over here and they had nothing
and, and all of a sudden like, you know,
you got some guy who came over here like,
you know, I was reading
this book about the, the I,
the famine in Ireland and like people
would come over here and like 1946 with
fuck,
you know,
zero and all of a sudden they went to
college and then they went to got a
doctor's license. Oh, it's banana
and became wealthy and it's like,
I,
I hope my kids like just break even.
I hope that they can move out
of the house at some point.
Make enough money to live on
their own. That's my, that's
my goal for my kids. Yes.
Wait, can I ask a question
though? Sidebar. He will.
He's a winner because he was, your son's
going to, he's the way you described.
Yeah, he should be. Well, you never
know. Sometimes kids peak in high school.
Your daughter is going to bring a
black guy to live with her for sure.
Gonna fucking definitely move on.
Yeah,
I'm expecting the black guy
were already like, you know,
putting hip hop stuff around the house.
It's just a matter of time,
stuff around the house.
You hang gold chains on the wall and shit.
So he's comfortable. We've got
some like, you know, some like, uh,
African elephant type statues and what,
what else do black people like?
We got cookbooks. Yeah. Yeah, for sure.
I want to ask you a question about the
potato famine in Ireland while there are
a fucking island.
Why weren't they fishing and eating fish?
We were fishing.
We were growing a multitude
of crops, but we were, um,
we were being held hostage
by the British who were,
who were exporting 99% of our agriculture
and then selling it to other countries
while we literally a million people
starved. It was a genocide. We'd,
they literally, you know, and so we
were subsisting off the potatoes.
And so when the potatoes went bad,
they didn't give us any of the other food.
We had giant, um, uh, pigs,
a giant,
a agricultural as well as
livestock all being exported.
And the Brits were like, fucking
let him die, let him die.
Literally said there are too many of them.
Let them die. And this is what yours.
Is this happening?
This was like in the 1840 [inaudible]
well the occupation lasted for hundreds of
years. 1840s. Now the British,
you talk about Nazi Germany,
the British are way worse in terms of
what they've done worldwide colonizing and
you know,
slaughtering all kinds of native peoples,
like the Spanish to Spanish by my
other half. Yeah. Savages. Yeah,
I remember. I still remember that.
I carry this with me, like those
moments, those conversations. I was in
this, I was in school in, in Madrid,
like in college, taking a class
and they were like, how do you, um,
when I write the teacher where
the professor wrote, you know,
when I write United States, what is
the first thing that comes to mind?
And a Spanish student was
like, imperialism, like, yes.
And world dominance and
then like what about Spain?
And they said some other shit. And
I was like, how about imperialism?
And he was like, excuse me. And I'm like,
you have like 600 million people
speak Spanish 2,600 miles away.
Yeah.
I think it's because they just liked
the language cause you guys fucking fuck
went in there and you just went in
there and just destroyed the place.
The most ancient civilizations,
the Aztecs and the Incas destroyed
their temples and their everything.
Their, their speech, they didn't allow
them to speak their native language.
And so it's, it's great. And pillage took
everything back and then all the goals,
they're like, you guys are
the imperialist. Like we
learned it from dad. Yeah,
dad that took all that gold.
Yes.
Because all of that goal in Central
America and they just carved it and the,
and it's the people in Mexico, they didn't
fucking know. Of course they did gold,
didn't mean anything to them.
So next thing you know,
they're hauling that shit
out of the ground with a gun
to their head. And anyway,
this is,
this has gotten to be a very dark,
I love it. Podcast. Yeah. We're on the
brink of civil war in this country.
And listen, we got to wrap things up. Um,
fits dog radio if it's a podcast.
So the show airs on Sirius Xm as well,
right?
Yeah,
I have the Greg Fitzsimmons show,
which had been on like 10 years
now on a Howard Stern's channel.
It's actually the only other show on
Stearns channel. That's crazy point. Yeah.
So you have that plus Mondays at a seven,
five o'clock on the West
close. So that'd be Xm
100101101. And then,
um, the podcast, you've been doing
that for awhile now, like eight years?
Um, I dunno, maybe tomorrow. Okay.
I'm not sure. I think tomorrow.
Yeah,
that's Fitstar checkout.
It's dog radio and a fits dog.com.
And then I got some tour dates,
kind of shit up those hours. Of course.
All right. I will be going to, let's see,
Spokane,
Washington November 2nd through the
fourth and then I will be in Atlanta,
Georgia at the punchline.
Uh,
November 16th through 17th through
the 19th. The all new Atlanta. I know.
What do you hear about it? I heard
good things. Yeah. I can't wait.
I like the owners. Um,
Tempe Improv December 14,
2017 and then,
uh,
and I think I may be adding some dates.
So good if fits dog.com
for more details. Don't even know. And
we say this, you know, we would say this,
it's uncomfortable to say to the person
you're the one of the best comedians in
the world of Humana. I've, I've like, I,
you're somebody who I 100%
if you're onstage, I want to watch and
then I feel badly about myself. Yes.
Wow. Yeah. And then I'm
like mad is he got a nice,
thoughtful Joe Rogan.
I were just talking about Greg [inaudible]
on Joe show last week whenever I did
it.
And you're so thoughtful and you're so
intelligent and you're so funny and it's
hard to be all those things and you're
really good. And I would say this,
you know, we'll always be, somebody
comes in here will be like,
you should go see their show. You know,
you shouldn't go see all the shows.
We tell you to go see it. But,
but we're full of shit. Yeah.
Fitzsimmons is so good.
If you love standup comedy and
you're in any of those cities,
you should a hundred percent good to take
it. He's, he's really one of the best.
So go see. Um, it's, it's awesome. Wow.
You guys are the best. That's very sweet.
My head is very big right now.
It's incredible.
It's so full of trees.
And don't forget as you go to bed tonight,
machines with machines with Shane's mate.
Thanks for coming today, man. All right,
appreciate it guys. We gotta run.
Thank you guys for listening.
We'll see you next week.
Why he to sit on different sides
of the bus tied to the bar.
My
left side to the prospect
public
boss,
Martina now considers herself black woman.
Good.
I don't want to watch your journey now.
I don't want to catch
you and have that awkward
big dog. Makes big shit. Small boat mix.
Small Shit owns get small
dog tied to the brush.
To the bras.
I took a brush.